this is a open forum
and um we're going to talk about the
open letter to kawasa Giant AI
experiments and that was published it
came
uh came out of a uh
organization which feels that we need to
be very cautious about Ai and this is
from my point of view a way of figuring
out
what people are thinking about this
um in any case I'm not going to provide
a great deal of early structure here but
if someone has an opinion they're
willing to open up the conversation that
would be it I would suggest you uh
unmute your uh
your uh uh microphone before talking
I've been reading verse snyers uh
newsletter and he had two different
articles on the risks here
this uh of this kind of thing he did not
sign the uh the Open Letter by the way
guys oh I didn't know that
um but uh his as I gather his main point
is the risk is uh
that these things will be trained to
manipulate the way people see certain
events that was one of the Articles the
other one was on how it makes lobbying
easier at scale
he pointed out the things that lobbyists
do and how time consuming that is and
how uh these tools can do the bulk of
that work at scale I mean do thousands
instead of one at a time who influence
uh legislators so that's my knowledge of
the subject and those seem like real
risks
well they may be real risk but um
don't we do that already well we have
lobbyists but
um it might take you know two lobbyists
a month or more
um to influence a legislator in some way
and these tools can influence a hundred
legislators in a day
that's the that's the that's what he
meant by at scale the difference is the
scale
isn't that the uh the beauty of uh uh of
having a system though one which uh is
automated and uh is efficient and uh
this isn't no different than anything
that we do currently it's just more
efficient right having a car to go
across the country
right right but there are things that we
we are happy to see be inefficient like
retail theft
we don't want that to be a hundred times
easier
well I'm not certain that is that if
you're you're in the right place that
may not be a uh uh a
uh that may not be a problem there are
communities where
um
that may be perfectly acceptable well my
point is that there are things that we
currently put up with because they're at
a manageable scale so we put up with
lobbying
um uh in fact lobbying has has great
value but we we put up with it because
it's at a manageable scale but what if
the influence was you know 100 times
more efficient that might not be
something that we would want to see
that's the point he's making I I've
never these things never occurred to me
well I mean you're a technologist I
think it's things that some of these uh
non-technologist people and Bruce is a
technologist by the way
um May uh I don't know yeah and then and
then the other one is
um uh today uh most of the
misinformation
is not tightly targeted to individuals
whereas at the scale of these AI they
can when they're giving me a response to
a question
um they can know a lot about me and
Target the response to me individually
and do that with every one of millions
of people who are trying to learn about
a given issue and that's another risk
right
and that's a reason for not uh not uh
allowing it to be developed further
well it's it's they're my my
understanding of the letter which I
didn't read was that we have these risks
and we don't know what to do about them
so let's slow down
uh let's not put out the make the Next
Generation available until we have a
handle on how to deal with the risks
that's my understanding of in the intent
of a letter
that's the understanding of the attempt
letter did you look at the is the um
uh looking at the uh listed signatures
is
definitely worthwhile
yeah and you know
um
I have a fairly uh Broad
uh knowledge base of uh who's doing what
where uh and uh the vast majority of the
Thousand experts are retired Emeritus
professors and uh professors of uh some
uh uh liberal arts uh field or something
like that they're not experts in
artificial intelligence
uh there are people who were quite
credible but they were actually fairly
few and far between and the population
that signed the letter yeah I've been
asked to sign these letters too where I
have no particular expertise and and I
simply said no but a lot of people would
would just sign on because you know it
sounds it's like people who sign
petitions I guess
um you know without thinking deeply it
sounds reasonable so they sign on
yeah but there are some very serious
thinkers on that list and uh
so it's worth worth uh thinking about
worthless discussion there were serious
thinkers in that list uh very few of
them but
um doesn't take a lot you know five out
of I don't care how many signed it a
million could have signed it but if five
serious thinkers think this is a problem
they're worth listening to us well okay
um at the risk of uh causing a
a bit of a Schism here was you believe
that Elon is a uh a serious thinker for
this field
I I don't think he's a serious thinker
about anything but that's uh
he's been he's been warning about this
for longer than most people this kind of
thing so yeah well the the people that I
you know I have several friends who
signed it
um
I'm not really sure that I
uh I think that most of the ones that I
do know that signed it really are
serious thinkers or the one of them said
well he didn't really want to have to
defend himself but uh he was thinking
about the problem doing some research
and he wasn't ready to talk about it and
so he thought it was a good time for a
uh a little moratorium so he could get
caught up
that's that's a that's a different
motivation it sounds like well it seemed
in many cases that the reasons that
people didn't want to sign on was that
it was
um not to their advantage
yeah that's true but I you know we have
seen
um evidence of risks
and
um you know this is a this goes back to
the atom bomb you know the first bomb
they said there was a a one in a
thousand chance they'd ignite the
atmosphere and end life on Earth
um you know I would have said wait
let's let's not take that chance that
penalty is quite High well
yeah but again you have to really when
you evaluate uh positions people have
you have to sort of evaluate them in
context and the people who thought that
that might ignite the atmosphere uh were
um
a little crazy I don't think they were
crazy I you know I I've read about that
I know the physics behind it um it was
deemed highly unlikely but uh not not it
not impossible there was no physics that
that meant it wouldn't happen but again
at this point I I'm reading
um articles you know newspaper level
articles not technical articles on on
various uh risks or the two that
schneier pointed out
um there's there's other risks in terms
of um uh what's it what's it going to do
the job market that people are worried
about my son has a job that might be do
might be doable by uh by one of these uh
AI systems and uh do we want to uh just
dive in or do we want to stop and think
well
uh well
of course the
the people who forecast this sort of
thing are is questionable is all the
rest of them
um but you know I just I just read an
article which said that
um they thought that roughly uh 75 to 80
percent of all jobs could be replaced by
AIS
I I don't buy that big a number because
we don't have we don't have sufficient
information yet but um in fact I just I
just had to do a stock transaction and
it was complicated so I spoke to a
representative there and at the end I
said Thank you you're much more helpful
than chat GPT
um wow I think there'll still be a need
for people
um but the question is uh
um what will the transition look like
you think that there's still a need for
people
uh yeah I think you're right there uh
first of all the thing that no one you
know the dirty dirty little secret is
that none of the uh various uh
uh
generative AI systems actually work
they sort of work and they're extremely
friendly they will happily create
articles supporting uh their their case
and footnotes and make not only the
article but you're asking it to make but
it's a footnote article that it
references as well
and it creates the amount of whole
thought and whether they're true or not
doesn't really much matter
but
um that's something that we'll probably
get fixed well there's there's two
problems that I see when it first came
out I was concerned about my son's job
he writes articles for the web for the
Santa Clara University website about the
athletic teams
to write an article about the most
recent women's soccer game and it wrote
a very nice article is the kind of thing
you'd see in any sports blog or anything
like that but it got the score wrong
that's that's embarrassing yeah well
um but the point is that it has no way
of knowing truth if there was a typo in
a uh you know in in some uh announcement
of the game it treats that as as correct
even though there's been a correction
added later it wouldn't it wouldn't have
a way to know so
um now that is that fixable without
having some broader context to evaluate
quality of information the answer I
think is yes uh actually fairly easily
but that's that's in a slight
modification of the training mechanisms
but yeah
it's uh it's it's uh trying to fix uh
fix it so it has a semi one shot like
thing right now I've been using it as a
as a search engine
uh experimenting with it and now I find
that often I can get the answer faster
from from chat CPT than I can from
Google
um so
um and I'm asking questions about code
so I know right away if it's right or
wrong but uh
but uh yeah so
I let somebody else talk yeah I'm good
I've said everything I know
well some that I don't I think to to uh
to take off with some of the beginning
session of the uh the recorder
but I'll just get that one person on one
well you're on one side and I guess I'm
on the other side
um
you're you're in favor of doing a
moratorium I'm in favor of
um of slowing down not not necessarily
more the research can go on
but releasing the new Earth the newer
systems to the public is the thing I
think I might want to wait on to see you
know have some evaluation of what the
impact might be not not that they
shouldn't do the research that's that's
I have no no problem with that but uh
just opening it up to the general public
we saw some really bad stuff with the
first main one
um
and uh what was the bad stuff that you
saw well the first one was the chat
engine that people trained you know all
of a sudden it was talking uh uh uh
anti-semitic and racist comments and you
know it was awful and they took that
down right away
um then they recently made it part of
Bing
um and um they made the the chatbot part
of things
yeah and well to answer to do searches
and uh didn't well didn't work well that
had the hallucination problem so uh uh
you know I think these things are not
well tested now part of testing is
opening them up but maybe not to
everybody but to small communities to
get them done I see a note here that uh
that some of these people are physicists
and I have a physics background and
my answer is just because somebody is
smart in one field doesn't mean they're
smarter than another one so I'm taking
those with the grain of salt I want to
know what their their AI
um
drops are before I I put a special
weight because a physicist signed this
letter
well I I I have I have a different View
um
I think that uh
trying to control the
experimentation here is going to cause
problems
and I think also that the economic
uh uh advantage of using this technology
is so great great that it's going to get
used regardless of what sort of controls
you put in well that's the uh that's the
open AI CEO he's he says he's scared of
it but but he's just going to plow ahead
because it's just too economically
valuable and and not just to his company
uh to the world I mean I'm finding
myself on more efficient because of it
yeah so do you uh do you believe that
the output from the AIS is uh uh
intellectual property is it a creative
uh uh creative work so the American I
have a PhD in astronomy and the American
Astronomical Society just put out a note
about using uh these systems to write
your technical articles and they do a
damn good job but they now say they must
be listed as an author if they do
uh-huh which means they can't be
copyrighted well the articles are
copyright no they can't be why because
they'll copyright office does not allow
a uh artificial intelligence agent to be
listed as an author at this point oh
even if there are human authors as well
even if they're human authors okay well
this the the American astronomical
journals are all open access now so that
may not be an issue for them
[Music]
well it's in it's it's sort of
interesting how this works
um the the intellectual property uh you
know
what's what's a creative act what's
what's a work of authorship
and what's derivative works
because the way the way in which the uh
the AIS basically work is is they
decompose the observations they make
about the entire world into very small
pieces and then uh they're
interconnected in various ways and then
there are you you effectively start out
with a a position in the universe and
you grow a uh a complete whatever it is
you're going for uh from that mud
that has been created by the uh by the
learning process
it's not clear that it's anything as a
derivative work in the sense of
copyright
but it's certainly based upon knowledge
which is gained gained by the computer
program observing other data
yeah well I mean it's uh it's an extreme
example of autocorrect when I'm typing
in Microsoft Word
but it's not different it changed the
words that I wrote
yeah that's right so there's a there
there must be a threshold then that the
copyright office is trying is is using
that I haven't heard articulated so by
the way uh there was an interesting
point somebody made the more things the
more times these things are used
the more of the generated text is out
there on the internet that they're using
to generate text oh yes so there sounds
like there's an exponential uh feedback
loop here
uh-huh
that is correct
and the the other the other thing is
that this is like the uh
there are papers we had a paper earlier
this year from uh a person who uh was
talking about detecting
the use of the AI in a uh
document that was created and could it
be detected and could you differentiate
well of course if you can't
differentiate then it becomes very
difficult to to say well you can
copyright these things but you can't
copyright those things yeah but the
other thing is uh any of any any any
process which
uses learned information to accomplish a
particular task
um then becomes questionable well that's
autocorrect yeah or um is auto correct
questionable I certainly is and in fact
you know in a very real sense chat GPT
is is sort of an extension of uh with uh
but it's an extension of uh uh of the uh
suggestions that now are presented as
you uh as you type in it right yeah uh I
want to respond to Bee's comment here
um I'm not in favor of uh pausing
research commercial and academic
research I'm
thinking about the benefits of pausing
the commercialization the opening up of
it to the general the general use
I think that's that's more
what I think we should be doing rather
than pausing the research I think the
research should go on because that will
give us the information to to know what
the effects will be all right no problem
with that but um uh opening it up to the
general public at a time when it's
uncertain what the implications would be
is like
um you know
um opening up uh certain biological
research that we think would be
beneficial long term but might have
harmful effects that we want to be able
to understand first
well the problem is that when you
separate and get people who get to use
it and people who don't into two
different groups uh that's uh that gives
one group power over the other
and well it depends on it that's a good
sign it depends on the restrictions you
put on how they use it now and who's
going to enforce them the the controller
of the we've done this forever in
software testing we've always lend it
out to small groups and told them here's
here's how you can use it and here's how
you can so for example the you know in
Mike in your company uh you may not make
it available to everybody we're testing
it with this set of five people and and
if you violate that you violated the
contract we do that all the time
right
but that is with that's primarily uh
I mean the law that's used for that is
primarily a non-disclosure law that's a
contract yeah and that's that's a reason
not an unreal and in fact uh the newest
one is these things are always rolled
out to small groups first
that's that's the way it's these have
been done
opening up opening up chat gpt3
um that was a that was a big deal but
four was used by by Modest size
audiences for months
and what they're saying now is let's
let's do five
finish it you know get it out there but
to uh small audiences not to the general
public and I I can't I think that's not
unreasonable
well okay
um
but I'm not in favor of of slowing the
research I think the research has to go
on because that's how we're going to
know
the best and the worst of it okay but
who does the research that's my question
whoever whoever gets the funding
if I sell Fun do I get to do research on
anything I want
well but up to your funding depends on
your your proposal
proposals oh yeah go ahead
hello everyone sorry I was late little
uh I was thinking about this uh thing
previously and the concept of AI winter
so uh here I think it would be good to
draw comparison maybe with Gene editing
technology which is also considered
quite powerful and there is specific
um regulations in place that may help to
actually regulate the process because it
is considered to be helpful but due to
the fact that not all
um about the snow one what genes are
responsible for specific functions so it
can cause certain issues and I think
here it also we may not know the social
consequences of this technology further
in the long run so I think the
proposition to slow it down uh is I I
find it um in certain extent beneficial
so of course it requires a lot of
evaluation how to actually do this but
it would help to put actually a
regulations in place to balance uh this
rapid quite rapid progress with the
benefits and actually drawbacks that
also existed so it is quite clear that
it was done by private companies and
this is why the slowing the approach so
not absolutely stopping which also uh
there's a question about this so and the
slowing down May benefit in production
of these regulations to make it actually
safe and sustainable in the long run
because
um there are still many questions that
it raises especially such powerful uh
updates
not currently going on and I think it
would help but the remote discussion how
actually it can help and more analysis
thing is required
yeah I have a friend who wrote a science
fiction novel about crispr technology
run amok and being stolen by evil people
um and uh
you know this this might fall into that
or the you know the virus research and
pathogen research but again I you said
to slow down the research I don't mind
the research what I what scares me is uh
the event General availability where
anybody can get their hands on the most
powerful current research
prototypes and that's the one that
that's the part that worries me I I have
less trouble with the research
proceeding
um because I think we will
learn
what the good parts are as well and
maybe how to control the bad bad effects
by the research and slowing the research
might affect both the good and the bad
but it's an appointment that's that that
has me a bit worried
yeah yeah I absolutely agree so maybe
the term research wasn't exactly the one
I was thinking about so the
implementation then because research
indeed provides this uh also analysis of
the situation so it would maybe also
depend the direction of research so how
would uh whether it goes further into
practice and how it goes into practice
so because making the AI winter actually
can have a negative uh consequences for
the maybe system functions also and the
possible
uh drawbacks that it brings so it also
question whether it is possible and
whether it is safe at all to have it so
can we actually maybe lose control over
the uh further progress in this area
so it also requires more evaluation
because I haven't seen too many papers
uh on the AI winter and how it will have
a social consequence or what actually
the like this evaluation
uh or the situation would happen and
maybe in general what some of the fears
in here uh the losing control
uh maybe it would be also beneficial to
have this kind of more control
um in a sense uh that we regulate uh the
technology by our regions
because currently it's a Implement sport
life and it is also quite complicated
in a sense
in by private companies and in uh how it
also draws on data from Europe and there
was an idea to have this kind of
established offices or certain uh teams
that cooperate and actually help to
bring the changes like ethical
regulations into place so actually
implementing this work on the
implementation
that would help to develop more
sustainable Ai and technology that is
based on AI yeah I I participate a bit
in the foresight Institute and they have
people worried about AGI artificial
general intelligence
um and that's a of even farther out than
the things that this is about
um but there uh the sense I get from
from what little I've read of their
stuff is they are think it's a positive
thing that AGI will be a have a positive
rather than a negative influence so but
the AI winter the AGI winter they think
it will be expanding human capacity and
they're working on ways to make that
happen so if you're interested you might
connect to the foresight Institute and
see what they're doing
they think about much more important
things than what I worry about
[Laughter]
I'm not certain that's true I'm I'm the
nitty bitty bits and bites and down in
the down in the dust kind of guy and
they're up in in space so you're you're
not you're not worried about the uh is
asteroid is coming to collide with the
Earth yeah that's that's pretty
practical though with this
[Music]
whether it is at all possible since
currently well
quite far from that level in my opinion
at least well there are different
opinions differences well they're
thinking 20 to 100 years ahead
like I read about 20 years but I think
it's still early quite early because to
actually cause a step of mind you need
something quite as strong as brain and
we still don't understand brain so a
mirror program cannot cause mind
which not many people understand yeah no
no they're uh
one of the things that they wrote us
this group that I'm they wrote a book
and one of the things one of the
chapters in the book is mining asteroids
and distributing the wealth evenly among
the across the entire popular I mean
these people are really out there so uh
uh so uh but but again
um you know their view is that AGI will
be disruptive but in overall you know
like any new technology there's a period
of disruption and at the end the world
is better off and that's their that's my
impression of their their View and
they're trying to make work to make sure
that that happens that it doesn't become
a problem and so that's that's the kind
of thing they're working on one one
issue I have with AGI I wrote a book by
Stephen Pinker about the brain and he
asked the question why would a robot
choose to do anything
he said you know why do we choose to do
anything
and and this was a whole chapter in the
book and and the point was his view was
we choose to do things because of
emotion
and if robots don't have emotion they
would never do anything except you know
plug themselves in to make sure they
they don't die but
um but why would they do anything so
it's it would be the humans asking them
to do things that set their goals not
the robots themselves
I mean I've I finally figured out why I
do what I do and it's I'm still trying
to impress my father I'm in my 70s and
I'm still trying to impress my father so
is your father impressed dually
he was how he was uh when I uh now it's
even harder to impress him now it's even
harder well I don't know maybe maybe it
isn't I don't know I see okay so uh yeah
when I started studying physics he he
was duly impressed
[Music]
I wanted to add maybe today did the AGI
and generally uh can live because other
youth is also from the perspective of
regulations and ethical implementation
and practice
so I think the issues that I have read
about and actually also so
um the certain actions that they're
taking instead
uh some focus on the AGI so much that
they actually miss the current
um issues and challenges like both
ethical moral and others that we face
today
so for example the Discrimination which
is uh one of the biggest issues and the
data
so that also can be biased in different
ways so which already exists today
because as we know like this biases get
automated and spread on a mass scale
which uh definitely is a complex issue
uh and um
so another thing is that
maybe I understand why you maybe hang
around around them because it's
interesting to know like what actually
the idea so what the concept there might
be and how they see to do this uh it I
think it's also
uh currently the focus is uh should be
more on a nearest term consequences
because when we look too far we just
lose our goal actually
um solving what we have now
what's your background what are you what
are you doing that this is interesting
to you
um uh I do a philosophy of technology so
particularly is uh ethics or artificial
intelligence and ethics of data but more
of AI it's algorithmic ethics as well
where where are you in Poland University
so
thesis on this topic and
um yeah so about policy making or social
impact
so I think this is my angle partially
here but yeah you should definitely
contact the foresight Institute they
actually have a foresight fellows if
they fund to do the kind of work you're
doing
yeah I think I actually read about it
maybe even took online course it wasn't
I don't remember was it poor side or the
Institute of future
um I just was curious about futurism so
uh features a lot of there's a lot of
overlap between us but yeah foresight
Institute would might might be
interested in in uh funding you the work
you're doing because it seems to be
quite close to what they're interested
in we'll have we'll have an opportunity
I think perhaps uh later this month for
you or Isaiah to meet some of the
foresight people
oh thank you yeah I will look into this
so uh I'm just really think that the
regulations are certain steps or
code of
uh ethical conduct is really necessary
in artificial intelligence especially
now because it's all fast going so when
I saw the proposal to actually pause
um
the
the progress that taken place in the
practice
so to uh like slow down the experiments
uh I found it it wasn't like a big
surprise to me and I do see a reason
so
um maybe it would be necessary because
some are supported for example in AI
powered worker that they will fall back
but I think they're building more
sustainable system in the long run is
more important than having a short-term
benefits because it will be beneficial
both for the country for people for
society support so
I think it shouldn't like some worry
that regulations as well as such a pause
uh can actually uh hinder the progress
but it is uh it is maybe true in the
short term but the long term it will
have good benefits plus people will
trust in a regulator and the well-built
technology rather than they will be
always worried and uh do not feel safe
to actually cooperate
so I think it's also important uh it's a
human element so that we trust so
trustworth AI or explainable high like
transport guys or concept more in Europe
than uh commission that they use they
focus on but
um explainable AI is you know maybe
popular so that we actually can
understand the decision and how
technology Works open I'm not opening up
the Black Box well have you have you uh
done have you you know how these things
work because I know that I know a lot
about the the guts of the inside I've
done a lot of work on the numerical
methods that they use inside of these
things I've never done the AI itself but
I've I've developed the algorithms that
they use inside of them and uh
explainable AI is going to be really
tough
yes
maybe that maybe we should focus some
more research on that but but I don't
know how it's going to happen I think
you can make a fairly good case for
explainable AI being a impossible case
well uh uh again in pinker's book one of
his conclusions was that in order to
understand our human brain we need
something more than a human brain and in
order to understand our AI systems we
need something more than the AI systems
and uh so well I don't think that the uh
the uh it can't be done
argument needs all that much uh support
because of the fact that it's basically
a uh probabilistic argument that the
number of possibilities which need to be
explored in order to work the problem
backwards is
this is just have a saying if something
isn't forbidden it will happen and every
prominent physicist that's ever said
that's impossible has been proven wrong
um
say that again unless it was forbidden
by me you and I can't have you can't
have a perpetual motion machine okay
that's forbidden by the physics but
everything that's allowed by the physics
event does happen oh yeah that's that's
uh that's uh David Deutsch's uh new
formulation of physics yeah so
um to say that that we will never be
able to explain the AI I expect that
something of the complexity of chat GPT
will be able to explain the decisions of
a very small AI system 100 neuron system
I think that's entirely possible we
don't know how to do it yet but I think
it's entirely positive but will the
largest
AI systems be able to explain themselves
that I have doubts
um okay uh I guess I I disagree with you
I don't think even a hundred neuron
system can be explained because most of
the information is not in the neurons
but rather in the data that the neurons
processing
and it's it's generated in the sense
that everything has been decomposed into
very small pieces and your choice of
what exactly is there is partially
probabilistic in the number of
possibilities gets to be very very large
very quickly
yeah sorry yeah uh there's also I
understand that this is complicated and
currently there there were like tries to
do like lime and shopping systems uh or
more like model uh models per
explanation so locally in the federal
model agnostic explanations and uh
played its explanations
uh those do have drawbacks but I think
it just shows that there is a step
forward explanation and like I just
mentioned maybe it is possible apart so
we start with this part but later we can
maybe explain already the whole system
so again as also Dennis mentioned it's
mostly in the data and there was like a
concept uh actually
this was General like an idea that we
should maybe look to Aviation
um
um field so sphere of uh activities
because it is happening regulated and
also in a sense that it for example uh
has such thing as uh their black box
already different one so the one that
record actually actions of a plane to
actually look into how certain events
unfold
so maybe in the sense so it would be
good to have explainable ai by Design
it actually takes a lot of effort so and
we're building AI into explainable uh
way it's maybe even more complicated but
the main goal is that human can
understand and explain the decisions so
maybe we do not have to see all the
details all the minor elements that took
place but we need to get a good idea of
what happened why it happened and
um explain uh to the people for example
since AI is also used in a social world
for example for credit scoring right to
get a loan it's already implemented uh
hiring mechanisms for job placements as
well as court systems that are also
already enforced so I think uh it's good
to even start this a little but I also
believe that it is possible to actually
explain AI really later on so it does
take time it's not so easy it also took
time to build AI so to explain it it
will also system and take some time but
step by step I think it's possible so
that um especially if you build
explainable air by Design so the
explanability systems already in place
before the product is already so it
would be much easier than explaining the
already ready one so there are also
um ways around it so I have studied
promo social Tech um social technical
perspective but I also looked into the
details and I actually found a really
nice presentation on that topic uh it
was a group of scientists it was a
conference also company by the paper
uh but there are small presentation of
their topic and uh
I got impression that actually there is
already going quite um
on Goods I would say
um there are possibilities to actually
make it now but it is still early and
complicated this is here once again by
pause may come beneficial to actually
more work on them
this side of explainability and how to
keep it controlled so how to actually
keep it stable and maybe while rooted
the experiment uh we work on this uh
more like safe pool so we know what's
happening and um I think you said
something very interesting that perhaps
the answer to explainable AI is to
design it from the beginning to be
explainable that we're unable
uh as Dennis said we can't even explain
simple AI system you know neural net
systems today but maybe some other
technology other than neural net
maybe separately or in parallel with the
neural net but it has to be designed
together we have plenty of examples of
things that are impossible if they're
designed separately
and uh relatively straightforward if we
design them together now I don't know
the research so I don't know if anybody
is doing that what I the talks I've
heard on explainable AI don't sound too
promising to me
but I was going to say uh but you know
decision tree is possibly combined with
statistical methods seem like
sort of that sort of approach
I also mentioned your comment that was
just about to address it
I think the decision three uh would be
nice but um it does not come from
uncertainty
so this is what AI generally also
nowadays do is please so this
uncertainty aspect
and uh because decision tree is closer
to uh previous types of AI but there you
so it may be it is good for an
explanation uh but it may be quite
complicated with the current because
they don't use as much decision trees
anymore
but it definitely could work like that
but yeah since the neural network is so
complicated and the black box it would
be you know aiming at opening this black
box so what's happening or at least it
gets an idea how it reached certain
conclusion due to all the info data and
uncertainty that it came into contact
list by the way in in the early days at
AI
um there were knowledge Engineers
um there were people who could do
amazing things and when you ask them how
they did it they couldn't explain it one
project we had I was working for IBM at
the time and this was in the late 80s
there were people who could schedule oil
tankers and optimize their trips
and they were all getting into their 50s
and 60s and getting close to retirement
and so they sent out people to ask them
how they did it and they could not
articulate how they did it
so
um there were people at Stanford I can't
remember the the person who the
professor who was leading the effort but
they developed a discipline for
extracting from them how they solved
these very hard problems
um and perhaps that's something that we
could use uh with these AI systems to
learn how they reached a certain
decision
um so maybe that's an area of research
that hadn't occurred to me before but uh
we had to do it with humans humans were
solving very complex problems and
couldn't explain how and AI is solving
very complex problems and can't explain
how so maybe we need this discipline of
knowledge engineering applied to the AI
I'm gonna have to go
uh it's nice to meet you Zoya and uh I
hope uh I'll run into you at a foresight
event maybe thanks bye
thank you
okay in any case you you used the uh the
the
uh crispr
stuff as an example
and uh there's uh it is a good example
because there is a fairly substantial
community of people doing
experimentation with genetic
modification uh on their kitchen table
um there's a store in Oakland California
run by Isaiah zentner called the origin
and there they sell all of the equipment
necessary including kits to experiment
with modification of your genetic
material particularly human genetic
material and so if you want to
experiment with your with yourself and
modify your genetic structure you can do
so with some other kids you can do it
locally or you can do it globally you
can
change the color of
the materials produced by E coli
bacteria from brown to red to green and
things like that and you can have
experimentation of modifying and doing
genetics I don't believe the kit the
mythical kit for blue in the dark
bunnies is available yet but there's
quite quite an amazing change in in what
goes on likewise you know people build
semiconductors at home now too
and so making computers is not
necessarily only the purview of a large
company could be a small company or
something you do uh in a in your back
garage
um and I I think I think Mike my concern
about regulating AI is the same I have
with any any regulation of of knowledge
it's not possible it doesn't work it
never works it always leaks out
um we even even you know probably the
closest tell them the secrets that we
have are how you how to build nuclear
weapons and it used to be only a small
number of people knew that and now that
that number continues to grow larger and
larger still not very large that's been
remarkably good
and in the days when the first of the
massive Weaponry was developed in the
11th century when the crossbow was the
first
brought out as a weapon War
um
there was a general agreement that it
was too terrible to uh to use and that
didn't last long
but at the same time it may not actually
prohibit everybody because as we know
some scientists do make Gene edited
projects especially the recent one when
the I think kids were Gene edited to be
protected from HIV finally
so but still I think what I hear is
yesterday
those individuals to the end but how
many actually cases the quote have
already prevented
so how many actually experiments on
humans were prevented by this regulation
because some are very eager but they
understand they would have to bear
responsibilities unless you're very
certain like that scientist was which
also still really affected deadly the
community even the creator of crispr she
was uh deeply
surprised and the wasn't ready for this
as well so because what the comparison
here is the power of the technology both
are very powerful
um
AI is not as your related but for
example Aviation it also relates to
society it's also powerful it carries
people yes it's Transportation but still
it has levels of certification it has
levels of trading so that would help so
I think certification
is what is actually lacking and needed
in AI
uh seems certification would also ensure
that the person could use I know about
not only technical elements how to build
AI uh well
we could also know about ethical
consequences and social impacts because
now some like they make their technology
may have an impact and they're like oh I
didn't know
I wasn't aware
um end of a story they can't be really
persecuted so or it just brought the
responsibility onto it and AI is also
complicated because it has many actors
so one is made this technology another
one trained the another one may be
distributed so who's responsible it's
like the famous question with Tesla car
it's pedestrian who's responsible
Tesla or maybe those would be data or
maybe the driver maybe the driver is
something so it takes time to actually
understand allocation of responsibility
it's also a big uh generally it's a big
question in machine ethics so who is
responsible for what and in General's
question regarding the female Society
because also the responsible is not
always to blame but they want to blame
and the responsible so there is also
differences in this but uh yeah I stand
for certifications uh that's uh
definitely because it is I think we're
unregulated right now
and I think just not not so safe uh and
Gene editing uh in that sense also shows
this how
um
that area is regulated and how it has
helped because again we do not know all
the long-term consequences how AI will
impact Society considering what we see
already now
and the same for genes you can edit the
gene that you may know responsible for
something but the issue with genius is
that it may be responsible for more than
one thing
and more than two more than three so if
there is Big questions how the gene is
connected to the rest of the system how
AI is connected to the rest of the
system how it impact Society because
generally AI reflects our biases and our
current issues because it used our data
which it feeds on and then later
plus the ideas of the developers or
trainers and then it gets multiplied so
I think I I think I agree very much with
your is your basic thrust here which is
that people need to know more about
what's going on and how it works
um and you know I have always been a
strong believer that uh people don't
learn enough science they don't learn
enough mathematics and they don't learn
enough history and enough ethics and so
forth to actually uh live in the world
that they live in
it's it's you know people are grossly
undereducated and you know we we're
particularly lucky here in the sense
that we have we're surrounded by a group
of people who
have had the opportunity to think and
talk about many of these issues but a
lot of people don't
never reach that level
and it's a big it's a big problem
well destroying definition and I was
thinking about this as well
so I thought uh actually to maybe make a
certain AI literacy program
that would uh maybe even on the side of
a user to start this because this is
where the most consequences happen and
go to the top
because regulation take long time
uh like even this gcpr it took like four
years I think to actually come into
effect so it was accepted on I think it
was 2000 uh 16 no maybe two years to
come into effect plus the earlier
development the proposals the decisions
so about four years all together so it
was accepted in 2016 and came into
effect in 2018.
and this considered to be quick it
considered to be quite um fast so the
actually the Revelation world is
Lightning behind it's too slow so again
this is where the post may come handy
but it's also like big question how this
post is implemented how it's done what
are the consequence because it's mostly
private companies that do that
so even since we live in quite
capitalist era and those companies I
think have quite capitalistic approach
so on financial gains uh good question
how we actually can convince them to
make calls
and but uh here is that my point about
literacy was that we have digital
literacy that was also quite an issue
when computers started to be
um available worldwide
so some governments actually had a
literacy program like Estonia
so in that since they had actually a
literacy programs so that's why it's
actually uh I think the only digital
government here so you can go online
like you can do anything online so it's
very comfortable and I think you can't
diverse online and mail that's what you
can do the rest you can do online except
maybe some minor things when you need to
actually bring the physical document
so yes but and they they had this
literacy program uh on digital literacy
so how things competitive so of course
it's not perfect and I see some other
things that they are not um aware about
but they have this basic skill for sure
if they know how to use emails they know
how to enter a system that's uh
to other people in some other countries
of the same age that uh some uh struggle
with this
and uh so the point uh that maybe we
need simple AI or generally how to use
digital more Advanced Technologies so
not only I but other algorithmic system
and maybe some social media for younger
people maybe also for older people too
so how to interact in social media
because it also relies on algorithms so
it also related to the topic so maybe
some kind of these programs to actually
explain what is going on
um and maybe also try to reach the
developers promote ethics because I
recently read quite nice people
uh from Rai Nita Shri I think he was his
master student or already graduated
and the paper uh proposed like this kind
of teams transdisciplinary teams that
will help to actually
navigate an AI and regulate and actually
make sure that ethical
a concepts are used
implemented because one thing is to
think about ethics and other things to
implement ethics so there is
uh this is one of the big challenges in
this um
reaching ethical AI
so do you believe do you believe that
there's some absolutely
absolute definition of ethics
an ethical Act is definable how
so I think there is no because uh we can
even formulate concretely like what is
ethics and all the ethical principles
here is the issue why we can't just put
ethics into machine and machine like do
ethics on its own or morality how do we
explain morality what is it to be moral
or some moral principles so what's here
the idea is more like so the known
concept of Ethics so more like General
that we can explain for example the
answer discrimination of Concepts or how
to place them this is something we can
elaborate but the absolute idea of
Ethics I think humans cannot elaborate I
mean like group of humans All Humans I
think it come together so many thinkers
and that's a big issue like concept and
philosophy so what is that it's it been
for so many years it's thousands and
years like what is ethical what is moral
so question of morality was a little
longer
and uh yeah so this I don't know
absolute definition of I said we don't
have even a definition of artificial
intelligence fully formulated which we
also need for the policies so how
actually we Define the eye the only way
like or a certain way that is accepted
on a regulation level so
about that you know
it's something which is neither
artificial nor intelligent
yes so it's so it then it was the
descriptive description by name because
it kind of slightly still different so
how we Define it how do we include all
its aspects because it's both it's study
and the technology
just the machine or the algorithm in the
machine it's actually a study of human
mind so this is how it started it was
like I mean before the Dharma of
conference there was another one it was
like about how machine can help start
your human mind
and then there was thermal from them
it's already
went into a different direction of
actually uh simulating or replicating
with possible and given a task but
through AI it was the idea that the
study of human mind a little that
detached from that maybe we come back to
that later
so I had one comment regarding ethics I
mean there was a recent like uh KCM
Communications article sort of pointing
this out that ethics usually uh applies
to humans you know we can say whether
humans are acting ethically or not and
they usually you know may make decisions
that are somehow programmed into
Machinery build build software Hardware
that does a certain thing uh but it's
hard to judge you know whether the the
software is ethical but you can
certainly look at whether the actions of
the designers and the companies and
everyone else and I think uh Zoya
brought up this really interesting
counter example of like you know looking
at social media where it was just sort
of rolled out as this massive experiment
on on Humanity uh without regard for the
consequences and so perhaps that's an
interesting comparison point to uh I
guess we're driving at that that it's
the the sort of commercial rollout and
impact on society that perhaps you
should think about
okay that's certainly true but you know
then the question is we don't do that
with anything else
and so I'm not certain that we
ought to do it with just these few
things that we do social media and uh
um artificial intelligence and um so
forth I that's oh you mentioned I mean
you mentioned you know Gene editing and
and the interesting question is yeah are
there certain technologies that have you
know
huge risks that maybe we shouldn't give
them out to everybody and they should be
restricted like you know like how to
build nuclear weapons is AI in the same
category it certainly seems like we are
an AI arms race do we want to distribute
those weapons to everybody at their
desktop right now I don't know maybe
I think we have
this fact is the fact is that even even
because even if we hadn't it will be out
there next week because once you find
out that it's possible people think of
different ways to do the same thing
and you know
Facebook it's too late argument
sorry what Facebook has plugins
and you know for GPD chat GPT and every
everybody is writing their program to
use chat GPT or gpc3 or two or one or
four or one of the other uh you know
systems and the the the in actual
faculty systems are pretty simple
um they uh they're not as complicated as
we want to uh to think they are
um they're they're actually pretty
straightforward
the the
data they operate on however is not
and it requires
fairly large investment of uh effort to
acquire the databases that are used
in those databases uh may or may not be
uh publicly available
and if they're not publicly available
then I think we have a real problem and
if they are then everybody has access to
some extent so it's it's it's a
complicated problem but it's one of our
own making
yeah uh it's definitely true and that's
also this is why the regulation is
necessary like engine editing because
it's not as complicated actually to do
Gene Edison like you need to search an
equipment that's true that's not widely
available but still because I I can do
it I can go down to the local drugstore
and get all the stuff I need or money do
you know why
um laboratory Laboratories that actually
do that so here's also the question so
when if it would be legal then it would
be many issues with this but AI there's
also idea of AI terrorism
because again data you can gather it
from social media but uh regarding or
maybe just the internet right or maybe
some companies sell it so this is the
data and yeah you can build it like if
your computer made the science student
and you had some practical classes so
it's possible
yeah I think I think you're right
in in actual fact what's interesting is
that
there's a major advantage to have to be
had economically and also socially uh to
be heavily into AI so people are
claiming that their system is an AI
system even when it's not
so we have that happening now we have
people using AI systems as as they were
designed to be and using them as just as
a tool and that works pretty well we
have people using it to create
scams and other bad uses and it's
extremely effective for that we're
having stories created all over
everywhere about things that people wish
were true and so we have an explosion of
apparent creativity which may or may not
be a good thing
um but
there's a lot more activity and a lot
more invention going on now with the
advantage of having a machine to do the
work
than we did before
um we
whether that's a good or a bad thing is
hard to tell but it's certainly not
something we wanted to have disappear I
think
and I don't think controlling it
particularly the people who would want
to do the controlling are probably not
the right ones to do it if even if that
were the case
your government Regulators for example
generally say no to everything at the
beginning because well it's safe
and you know I'm not not certain that
that's that's ideal for everybody or
even anybody
so regardless uh this also Concept in um
policy making that indeed most policies
is like don't do this don't do that uh
it's not allowed it's not allowed but
um there are different ways actually how
to
um regulate something
so there is also more like not always
some legal enforcement it can be like
again code of conduct we also can buy
can be binding locally it also can be
more like a recommendation that if you
don't do this like you for example Max
corporate social responsibility right
that's so important
that like if you do this it's unethical
conduct uh which also kind of has to
effort because people won't choose for
example if it's especially public
something and about awesome
social media scandals like uh that also
be mentioned uh like also the case with
Cambridge analytica very famous so uh
does it used to analyze profiles of so
many users
so here's this social media experiment
so that they were actually allowed to do
this and this later sell this
information and
yes and even the point of manipulation
so people can get manipulated especially
vulnerable groups because a use of
Internet usually implies that you are
healthy adult but there are many kids on
the internet there are many vulnerable
people who don't have full mental
capacities for example so it's also the
world is quite diverse and different
rather than I don't know only one
perfect ideal concept of human who uses
internet is present so uh yes this is
why it may not fully actually offer this
uh 100 protection but it would
definitely reduce their risks and harm
if we start to actually certify
developers or trainers that there could
be different categories of certification
so the question I found it already like
twice it's not so popular so many
regulations actually are more like do
good or more no do not discriminate
reduce bias so in in make groups diverse
so
[Music]
is making that they start talking about
is that
we should also the the issue that it's
not only what people and developers have
to work on it's also policy makers
because before it maybe it was so easy
to say don't do this end of the story so
don't don't queue it's very bad but here
it's more like you have to with this
technology explain how why and actually
like the ways to do this so often
approaches so maybe the law and the
regulation to say don't do that or in
certain way like explain the situation
that may not be allowed but later either
supplemental documents can uh Aid in
actually how to reach this ethical level
that is required or
um
maybe all singular regulation itself for
example like the sustainable
developments they also have certain
regulations that uh kind of limit the
symbol for example
um
production and also there are quite many
documents that actually would help
business or a certain cooperation to
actually reduce the steps how to achieve
a lower
uh CO2 Mission so because it's also
important for policy makers to actually
explain if they want people to follow
especially with such technology that is
based right it also uh quite available
it's not prohibited So currently it also
requires like certain ways how to do
this and yeah but uh the biggest worry
is the
time in between between we actually
reach ethical and moral machine and
uh from now so what happens in between
whether there will be some related
disasters and when do we reach this
ethical or more ethical uh technology
now ethics and morals tend to be
Frameworks of belief
and they don't seem to have uh any uh
intrinsic or intrinsic
importance in the way in which uh
the actual
presence and being of things are
that is to say you can be a moral person
or not and you know still live a
perfectly ordinary life
or ethical life or
um so so it's it's not it's not a it's
not a separable uh
separable thing and it's not not really
a property of the physics of things it's
more of a property of our belief
structure
um and that's part of the problem uh one
of the things that is really intrigued
me which led me to my belief that the
singularity slip in not too long ago is
that about about a year ago
uh everyone who is doing research in AI
I know started studying ethics
now the question is why would they do
that
yes
and they're probably trying to figure
out what their systems are doing and why
they're whether that's an ethical thing
or not the chat bot we were talking
about the one that learned how to be
anti-Semitic and uh so forth uh
it had nothing to do with AI
had nothing to do with the data that was
there had to do with the the data that
got put there and created by the by the
people who uh fed information and
examples to it so it's really a
reflection of our society and nothing
has nothing at all to do with AI at
least that would be my argument
definitely so this is one of the points
that I actually tried to explain is the
idea of ethics and what it includes
right unethical because it reflects
society and the issues that we have
again get automated and distributed on
mass scale yes
limited person who can't limit AI for
example on social media because it has
certain embedded ideas of the developers
or data it has and also recently I read
quite interesting idea that maybe it is
also necessary to prosecute people I
mean I mean there may be different ways
how to do this and the degrees the
person people who actually train AI is
malicious at pay an attempt to harm
Society
that would be interesting I think that's
very dangerous thinking actually
because
I wanted to follow up on that I mean
there is this uh a couple interesting
things one is that you know going back
to like ACM they've you know drafted
this what I think is you know in many
ways a pretty good ethics policy uh
which would seem to forbid a lot of
activity uh performed by various
companies like Facebook yet they've been
rather reluctant to actually punish or
discipline any any to sort of enforce
their policy but it's possible they
might in the future which would be
interesting so there's this possibility
that professional organizations could
Institute ethical Frameworks and
possibly decide to enforce them although
they haven't in the past in Computing
but they might
then then there's this other idea you
know where like software and really I'd
say the software industry especially is
completely Dodge any concept of
liability uh but of course once you know
software is in a self-driving car and
the car hits someone there's clearly
liability issues so as you mentioned
like sorting out those liability issues
May clarify the legal regime and then
going back to you mentioned Cambridge
analytica they're sort of you know
well-known sort of standards for uh kind
of human subjects research right that
were violated in that case and that's
sort of another angle that possibly
those could be applied as well
actually I believe in Cambridge
analytics uh there was a release that
was a couple of layers back that
everyone signed that could it if you
close your eyes and sort of paint your
nose you could probably say it allowed
the information to be gathered but not
shared and then it was shared
I mean yeah there are a lot of sort of
questionable things one is you know the
legality of these click-through
agreements that nobody can figure out or
they perhaps don't understand or perhaps
legally can't consent to uh because
they're not bound by the contract or
something and then there's also this
idea of like well did the did the insta
did the uh like the IRB appropriately at
Cambridge or wherever appropriately
approved this study and then there's the
question of you know did they actually
violate even if the contract was valid
did they violate it right but I don't
remember the specifics but
several years ago I had a speaker who uh
was extremely difficult to convince that
she ought to come and talk about uh the
case law of which there is a substantial
amount that says that you don't have to
do a put through at all you just have to
visit the site
and you you're automatically co-opted
into the uh
regulations that relate to the site that
are posted somewhere on the site but
without uh having any guaranteed that
you read them in the neural word
and by the way reading it or being aware
of a document doesn't really constitute
agreement or uh understanding either so
I mean there's a whole lot of uh
real issues about understanding and
belief and uh models that you have about
how to operate within the universe that
are sort of left very much open and it's
like copyright on the internet now
if you put something on the Internet
Internet you give up copyright or not
well you don't but you do sort of
because there's fair use and things like
that
is an interesting concept a very
difficult concept
this is why again we come back to the
idea that AI actually reflects all these
things so this can come together because
again we talk about simulated
intelligence
so and this all things like like breach
of contract is you know it's not AI
specific but it also is an AI so the
things like multiple of an ethical Norms
well it's common I mean I hope not
but you know it is present so it is also
everywhere else so we should not forget
the some issues uh actually human
uh existed for for quite a long time uh
and even some technical aspects so they
may be related to actually the
informational communicational
Technologies ethics so the communication
ethics rather than AI specific things so
just com comprised of many different
elements that come together and do have
an impact when
uh seen as a wonderful so I think there
are ways to to
um
involves ethical uh the actually
implement the ethical principles that we
was talking about earlier so uh that not
all companies follow it uh true but
there is two companies they do and I
mean actually this limit uh the issue so
of course can we ever reach 100 Kevin
can we ever have something perfect so I
adopted but uh we can be close to
Perfection we'll be close to the uh more
healthy societies so I think uh it's
also good I think we can certainly
improve things
yeah we can definitely improve so if
even if it's not uh something like Final
Destination that we're looking for uh
still the enhancements they do bring
value and AI is useful it does many
great things it just the drawbacks are
quite significant and this is just a
short term because AI was possible to
actually build quite recently so it's
not that old
um technology
so it was taught longer before but it
wasn't possible to make so there is also
important to keep that in mind so the
actual societal effects are quite uh
fresh in the sense so what happens in
the long term and about social
experiment experiments that we also
mentioned is that some the social
networks they actually manipulate beats
in the
without consent as I understand
um of users to do their own experiments
like Facebook did it used like 600 000
users and um
it actually manipulated their feeds so
for some it made more negative like more
negative posts and fathers more positive
and look what happens and then they
analyzed their posting history and these
users who saw more negative news more
negative information they started
posting for negative information same
was for the positive answer it's like
having your manipulation and so how it
can actually because some may not even
mention but we actually already quite
used to our phones and we look into this
and it's called like hand machine so
it's always in our hands and all this
nearby we always spare it on ourselves
some even feel like safe when bonus is
done so it really got embedded in our
everyday life so this is why it's also
important to
kind of regulated for a safe use and uh
so I think yeah there was some other
point ah LinkedIn I remember it's
another example LinkedIn also made their
own experiment
so they are provided for some users more
opportunities like more jobs opening
conversation Wireless for others and so
what's happening
job essential like important aspect in
the lives of humans so somebody was a
left with less opportunities for the
sake of experiment and as a member there
was no consent involved
so here's also company to play what this
companies can do uh these are the
regulations so it's not they're not
ethically bound to actually explain so
we do need ethics at least on their more
public levels so because public can also
have the power to reinforce such things
like we have musicology so of course it
may be
a bit different type of example as it's
still important to understand how
different policies work in apology and
AI or woodwork because uh yeah there are
its own challenges but I think uh yeah
so it would still be positive
I think that's
that's exactly correct
I think um we need to call it call it an
end today thank you very much so it's
marvelous chatting with you as always
um it turned out that we ended up with a
three-week conversation it would be uh
thank you for his contribution and for
the others and for very early on but I
think I think it was just uh it's a good
conversation we're going to slip out
this uh our little piece here and it
will be uh on the web and it'll be very
nice thank you